[Musica]
l'anno che verrà è investito dei timori
delle speranze dai pensieri dei
ragionamenti dalle ipotesi dalle
convinzioni dalle illusioni dai dubbi e
dalle certezze di miliardi di persone
insieme potremmo dire contemporaneamente
e concentricamente sul tema centrale
della salute individuale e di specie
penso che ciascuno di noi abbia una
parte di sé perennemente dedicata a
immaginare come sarà come andrà di
questo vorrei parlare oggi della nostra
immaginazione
però vorrei parlarne in questo modo non
tanto dicendo anche io la mia su come
immagino che sara l'anno che verrà
o su come immagino che andranno le cose
vorrei piuttosto fare una specie di
capriola immaginativa vorrei provare a
immaginare quale tipo di immaginazione
ci sia richiesta per fronteggiare questa
situazione nella sua portata planetaria
e nella sua discontinuità con il passato
recentissimo vorrei provare a immaginare
quali caratteristiche la nostra
immaginazione dovrebbe avere per
immaginare l'anno che verrà intesa come
metafora per dire il futuro il nostro
futuro cioè propongo un esercizio di
mera teoresi quindi propongo di
immaginare le caratteristiche della
nostra di cui la nostra immaginazione
dovrebbe dotarsi dunque la mia proposta
immaginiamo come vorremmo che fosse la
nostra immaginazione per riuscire meglio
a immaginare il nostro futuro vorrei
suggerire di immaginare i miglioramenti
e l'evoluzione della nostra
immaginazione seguendo tre dorsali cioè
tre linee che spiccano nel nostro
immaginario territorio
dell'immaginazione come se fossero tre
catene montuose che la percorrono tutta
oppure contrario 3 faglie
quelli che l'amavano tutta nelle sue
profondità
proviamo a immaginare allora queste tre
dorsali queste tre linee di evoluzione
delle quali magari far emergere anche
una prospettiva la prima la chiamerei la
dorsale associativa la seconda è la
chiamerei la dorsale radicale e la terza
la chiamerei la dorsale dei tempi
liquidi loro sale associativa una
meravigliosa caratteristica
dell'immaginazione umana forse la sua
caratteristica fondamentale è quella di
sapersi allontanare dalla realtà per
dare vita ad altri mondi
sebbene come direbbe leopardi questi
siano mondi illusori
ma è proprio nella lontananza della
realtà nell'illusione che la nostra
altra facoltà meravigliosa vale a dire
la ragione trova materiale da pensare da
erodere anche da demolire e da
distruggere tuttavia senza questi mondi
da affrontare persino da demolire la
nostra stessa ragione finirebbe per
trovarsi inaridita inutile per così dire
sterile e a lungo andare potrebbe
persino spegnersi in questo movimento si
può che può apparire paradossale la
funzione dell'immaginazione fondamentale
non solo per se stessa ma anche per
l'altra fatica dalle facoltà cioè per la
ragione
chiameremo questa caratteristica
dell'immaginazione facoltà capacità
dissociativa cioè la capacità di
espandersi e di sganciarsi dal mondo
reale per creare versioni diverse e
molteplici di altri mondi
proprio questa capacità dissociativa io
immagino che sarebbe importantissimo
affiancare una capacità associativa
complementare che possa completarla e
anche farle evolvere vogliamo immaginare
questa capacità
immagino la capacità associativa
dell'immaginazione come una capacità di
portare dentro il mondo reale
i frutti partoriti altrove dalla sua
capacità dissociativa applicando una
forza centripeta alle proprie invenzioni
e una forza di gravità che la riporti
sullo scalo territorio del reale
immagino un movimento doppio quindi
dell'immaginazione che prima si
allontana dalla realtà e che poi vi fa
ritorno come un pescatore che lancia
delle dalla sua vuota imbarcazione delle
reti e poi la richiamo indietro
l'impegno della barca di pesci dal vuoto
al pieno la dorsale associativa la
penserei così come un miglioramento
della nostra immaginazione che si dota
di auto d'orta della capacità di questi
stand data lontano lontano lontano di
tornare indietro carica di contenuti con
cui arricchire la realtà sotto sale
radicale a noi parliamo di immaginazione
al singolare per riferirsi una facoltà
umana ma quando poi andiamo a vedere
come l'italia facoltà si manifesti nella
nostra vita di specie vediamo che i suoi
frutti crescono su tanti rami
diversissimi arte sport letteratura
tecnologia musica danza chimica scienza
medicina finanza informatica ogni
aspetto dell'attività umana e non solo
di quella culturale in senso lato
presenta i frutti della cosiddetta
immaginazione i rami di cui parliamo in
volta fori camente si sono via via nel
tempo sempre più ramificati appunto cioè
le nostre aree d'intervento nel mondo ci
sono sempre più specializzate e
all'interno stesso di ciascuna
disciplina le modificazioni si sono
moltiplicate e la nostra distanza per
cosiddetto uomo leonardesco cioè la
figura di un uomo in grado di eccellere
simultaneamente tanto nell'ingegneria
quasi una pittura tanto nella musica
quanto nell'urbanistica eccetera
appare ormai incolmabile
abbiamo dovuto diversificarci abbiamo
dovuto specializzarci diventare sempre
più sottili per penetrare dentro
sempre più a fondo in ogni ambito la
funzione dell'immaginazione specifica e
immaginare per esempio nuovi servizi
finanziari non è immaginare nuove
applicazioni informatiche e non è
immaginare nuove particelle subatomiche
nei nuovi romanzi polizieschi e così via
il prezzo da pagare alle 3 la nostra
specializzazione è una parcellizzazione
crescente del sapere e per quel che
riguarda noi adesso una partecipazione
per un crescente dell'immaginazione
possono chiamare capacità floreale
questo aspetto della nostra
immaginazione che riesce a far fiorire
ea fortificare al culmine di
ramificazioni sempre più sottili e
sempre più lontane fra di loro come le
estremità della chioma di un albero
gigantesco che continua a crescere
diciamo che immaginata così questa
caratteristica della nostra
immaginazione non sembra avere nulla di
incompleto da devolvere ma tutti questi
fiori
tutti questi frutti che fioriscono e
maturano negli estremi sono sempre più
lontani gli uni dagli altri
pertanto proprio a questa capacità
floreale della nostra immaginazione
io immagino che sarebbe importantissimo
affiancare una capacità radicale
complementare che possa completarle
farle evolvere vogliamo immaginare
questa capacità la capacità radicale
dell'immaginazione
secondo me dovrebbe ristabilire un nesso
vitale che rischia così come siamo ora
di perdersi ma non si tratta e non può
trattarsi di un nesso che metta insieme
che raduni insieme i frutti fiori della
nostra metafora arbore quello che
abbiamo visto prima del fortino che si
allontanano sempre di più non possono
meno un po metterle insieme perché
sarebbe una marmellata sterile rim
pasteur ebbe in qualcosa che è poi
amorfo
io immagino al contrario che nella
dorsale radicale travi il posto
movimento che da ciascun fiore da
ciascun frutto lontano
la nostra adolescenza torni giu
ritorni verso il tronco che maggi di
questo questo movimento verso il tronco
e verso il titolo di questo albero e non
solo verso il tronco ma anche verso le
radici di questo albero un movimento che
riconosca e che renda effettivamente
riconoscibile l'origine comune di tutte
le nostre immaginazioni movimento che
sappia ritrovare ritornare allo scuro
terreno dove tutto nasce dal terreno
nelle zone comuni di una materia opaca
trasformata da noi incessantemente in
nutrimento la dorsale radicale secondo
me è la direzione seguendo la quale
dobbiamo la nostra immaginazione
floreale suo movimento a ritroso che la
completa e la fai valutare se ciascuna
delle nostre specializzazioni deve
svilupparsi in una sua propria direzione
e quindi distanziarsi dalle altre la
dorsale radicale deve togliere
l'angoscia della solitudine ai fiori ei
frutti delle immaginazioni settoriali e
specialistiche riportando ciascuno in un
quadro più complesso e ricco nel quale
l'unità fra tutte è sempre già garantita
tra le radici comune e non via via
sempre più perduta
questa capacità radicale di cui vorremmo
dotare la nostra immaginazione per
renderla più in grado di immaginare
l'anno che verrà
mi rendo conto che non è semplice
immaginarla penso tuttavia che sia
importante farlo perché il contro
movimento radicale potrebbe abbassare il
livello di angoscia della solitudine di
ogni prodotto dell'immaginazione
meramente floreale la dorsale dei tempi
liquidi una caratteristica della nostra
immaginazione e quella di immaginare il
futuro
la dimostrazione che oggi stiamo qui a
immaginare l'anno che verrà
questa caratteristica è uno dei
presupposti su cui si fonda anche la
caratteristica dissociativa che vedevamo
prima di cui abbiamo parlato quale mondo
che non sia questo mondo possiamo
immaginare beh in primo luogo il mondo
ora non c'è ma possiamo immaginarlo
possiamo immaginarlo probabilmente
dobbiamo immaginarlo proprio perché non
c'è io chiamerei questa capacità
dell'immaginazione la dorsale dei tempi
solidi come immagine possiamo pensarla
come il movimento di costruzione che di
pietra su pietra e riga una torre ogni
pietra presente diventa la pietra
passata su cui si fonda la pietra futura
che così diventa presente e poi di nuovo
la sua volta passata e così via
nella dorsale dei tempi solidi la nostra
immaginazione e costruttiva e
indirizzata e addizionale e potremmo
vederla anche come progressiva in questo
senso credo che sia proprio la dorsale
dei tempi solidi di necessitare
profondamente di un completamento che ne
sia anche l'evoluzione e chiamerei
chiamerei questo questo completamente
questa evoluzione la dorsale i tempi
liquidi lungo la quale penso dovremmo
cominciare a immaginare la nostra
immaginazione una dorsale che le
permetta di porsi nei confronti
dell'anno che verrà con più robustezza
con più forza ma al tempo stesso con più
agilità proprio la nostra immaginazione
margin ha immaginato che il tempo non
sia poi così semplicemente quella
freccia lineare che del passato va verso
il futuro infilzando il presente come un
pollo allo spiedo e proprio la nostra
immaginazione ad aver nutrito le più
sofisticate versioni tempi non lineari
sia nella sia nelle scienze sia nelle
arti sia soprattutto nella letteratura è
necessario qui che l'immaginazione
faccia la capriola forse più importante
di tutte quella di immaginarsi
svincolata dalla metafora del tempo
lineare di immaginarsi libera non solo
di immaginare di immaginare il futuro ma
di immaginare il passato può sembrare un
paradosso
forse lo è forse deve esserlo immaginare
il passato pensiamoci su immaginiamo
come si possa fare
e poi non solo immaginario
il passato immaginare anche il presente
sembra addirittura una frase senza
significato bene
e proprio per questo è richiesto
l'immaginazione che vi ha significato a
una frase così bislacca immaginare il
presente
questo è il senso della dorsale dei
tempi liquidi immaginarsi movimento
della nostra stessa immaginazione che
affianchi completi e face volvere
l'immaginazione dei tempi solidi dalla
quale peraltro è il prodotto più
raffinato e importante secondo me vedere
la dorsale dei tempi liquidi e quella
dei tempi solidi non sono in
contrapposizione è importante vedere
come la prima nasca dalla seconda un po
come la meccanica quantistica nasce da
quella classica ma in un movimento
complessivo enormemente più ricco e
maestoso se oggi che possiamo immaginare
una dorsale dei tempi liquidi per la
cosiddetta immaginazione
lo dobbiamo a secoli di immaginazioni
che si sono stratificate una sull'altra
in un movimento di tempi solidi la
dorsale dei tempi liquidi potrebbe
aiutare l'immaginazione a immaginare
l'immaginazione che sfida il futuro
anche semplicemente ne raccolga le sfide
immaginiamo di dotarci di un
immaginazione che oltre a immaginare il
futuro immagini passato e immagini il
presente e così facendo prendere di
petto anche l'idealità del tempo stessa
che si trovi a suo agio nei paradossi
temporali e che da qui
parte a immaginare anche spazi diversi
non sono tempi diversi
finora inimmaginabili un'immaginazione
che colonizzi l'immaginabile che nel
esposti gli equilibri con quello che
finora è stato già immaginato
in conclusione dotiamoci di questa
immaginazione voluta non aspettiamo
passivamente che l'anno che verrà
ci lasci fa cc lanci sfide a cui reagire
sfidiamo a noi per primi immaginiamolo
immaginando con lui anche tutti gli anni
passati
immaginando con loro anche l'anno
presente immaginiamo che la nostra
stessa immaginazione si è evoluta
immaginiamo la lungo queste tre dorsali
che abbiamo detto
immaginiamo la newco non in lungo
innumerevoli altri dorsali d'altra parte
ogni cosa può essere immaginata il
meridiano la su altre dorsali di cui
anche non sappiamo nulla
e proprio perché non ne sappiamo nulla
possiamo forse dobbiamo immaginarci la
ma comunque dopo i movimenti delle tre
dorsali che abbiamo visto adesso sono
secondo me sono la dorsale associativo
abbiamo detto che è completa ed evolve
la capacità dissociativa la dorsale
radicale che completa devolve la
capacità floreale e la dorsale dei tempi
liquidi che ne completa ed evolve la
capacità dei cosiddetti tempi solidi
questa immaginazione mi sembra che si
arricchisca in maniera adeguata per
immaginare appunto l'anno che verrà
inteso come il primo e prossimo pezzo di
futuro con cui avremo a che fare
questa immaginazione dunque a tre
movimenti che si aggiungono a quelli
soliti completandoli e completano mi
sembra rendendo l'immaginazione non una
facoltà più astratta o complicata ma al
contrario rendendola più concreta direi
fisica che addirittura corporale sono
movimenti di diastole che è completa
l'asystel e di ispirazione che completa
l'ispirazione di sonno e anche di sogno
e completa la veglia
ma l'immagino pulsare questa
immaginazione la vedo vivere dentro
dentro un ritmo vibrante e movimento
me lo immagino come un luogo
multidimensionale e in parte misterioso
dove accadono eventi che non sappiamo
descrivere ancora bene
non vorrei però sottrarmi alla consegna
di immaginare l'anno che verrà
non vorrei che questo gioco di
immaginare l'immaginazione lasciasse
totalmente priva di contenuti
l'immaginazione del tempo che sta
arrivando
allora vorrei semplicemente dire quali
secondo me sono tre fra gli innumerevoli
temi o argomenti o capitoli chiamiamoli
come vogliamo su cui dovremo sicuramente
fare un'importante notevole lavoro
immaginativo qualunque sarà
l'immaginazione di cui disporremo la mia
è una piccolissima lista del tutto
personale due sono il potere e il denaro
il terzo punto che non riguarda certo
solo l'anno che verrà e gli anni che
verranno ma soprattutto forse tutti gli
anni e tutta la vita
il terzo punto è la libertà grazie